vemos que en rne es dos años mayor que
el día día tiene dos años qué edad tiene
un gran los ánimo que pongan pausa en
este vídeo y traten de resolver esta
pregunta por ustedes mismos traten de
pensar qué edad tiene en rne aquí vamos
a usar unas letras que representarán la
edad de día y de ingram digamos que es
la edad en rne y es verdad en rne y b es
igual a la edad de día v es igual a la
edad de día ahora qué nos dice esta
oración esta primera oración que tenemos
aquí que irán es dos años mayor que día
la edad de imran es igual a la edad de
día más dos es igual a la edad de día
más dos en rne es dos años mayor que día
otra manera en la que podemos pensar en
esto es imaginar una recta numérica que
nos representa las edades y la voy a
dibujar de este lado
podemos decir que aquí está el cero y
aquí está la edad de día aquí ponemos la
edad del día y si avanzamos dos vamos a
sumar dos a la edad del día y obtenemos
la edad de imran sumamos dos y obtenemos
la edad de imran esto es lo que nos dice
esta primera oración y luego nos dice
qué día tiene dos años o sea la edad de
día es 2 esto es lo mismo que decir que
de que es la letra con la que
representamos de edad de día es igual a
2 así que esta vez también la tenemos
por acá es igual a 2 esta de que tenemos
aquí es igual a 2 y podríamos reescribir
esto de la siguiente manera miren la
edad en rne es igual a la edad de día
que es dos más dos y cuando es dos más
dos ustedes saben eso claro que si dos
más dos es cuatro dos más dos es cuatro
y lo escribimos aquí la edad de imran es
igual a cuatro si esto que tenemos aquí
es dos y avanzamos dos
vamos a llegar a 4
vamos a ver otro problema como éste aquí
nos dicen la jirafa de zoológico es tres
veces más alta que santa no santa no
mide seis pies
cuál es la altura de la jirafa una vez
más los animo a que pongan pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar en esto por
ustedes mismos vamos a usar la misma
idea vamos a usar letras que representan
las diferentes alturas entonces usaremos
la j para la altura de la jirafa y ese
para la altura de santano y nos dice que
la jirafa es tres veces la altura de
chanta no usamos la j para la altura la
altura de la jirafa y fíjense bien tres
veces la altura de santano no dice que
sea tres pies más que la altura de
santano sino que es tres veces la altura
de santano entonces la altura de la
jirafa es tres por la altura de santana
la altura de santano y recuerden que la
j nos representa la altura de la jirafa
y la s nos representa la altura de
santano otra manera de pensar en esto
y dibujar una jirafa y voy a tratar de
dibujar una jirafa de este lado entonces
esta es mi jirafa es un intento de
jirafa le pongo sus patitas largas
aquí dibujo mi jirafa y nos dice que la
altura de la jirafa es tres veces la
altura de santano esta altura es igual a
j aquí escribo la j y la altura de
santano aquí tenemos que poner la altura
de santa no nos dice que la altura de la
jirafa es tres veces la altura de
santano así que vamos a dividir la
altura de la jirafa
todos y digamos que aquí está cantando
aquí ponemos achantó no y que está es
tres veces su altura una vez dos veces
su altura y tres veces su altura
entonces con tres veces de altura de
llanta no obtenemos la altura de la
jirafa esto que nos dice la primera
oración santa no mide seis pies de
altura así que esta altura que tenemos
aquí es igual a seis pies otra forma de
verlo es como dijimos al principio ese
es igual a 6 pies y tenemos que saber
cuál es la altura de la jirafa bueno
aquí vamos una vez más sabemos que ese
es igual a 6 pies
entonces la altura de la jirafa es igual
a 3 por la altura de santano que es
igual a 6 y sabemos que 3 por 6 es igual
a 18 y como estamos usando pies la
altura de la jirafa es igual a 18 pies y
lo podemos ver aquí 6 pies más 6 pies
más otros 6 pies es igual a 3 veces 6
pies
3 x 6 que es lo mismo que 18 pies